It did have the biggest red eyes. There's
a six-foot bird and massive wings.
I asked her how big the wingspan was, she
said about 10 to 12 feet. Is Point
Pleasant haunted? Yes very much.
I'm here in Point Pleasant West Virginia.
The little Appalachian town with a big
monster history. It's home to one of
America's most notorious legends -Mothman.
Described as a humanoid creature with
massive wings and glowing red eyes, this
man with wings was first spotted in this
area in the 1960s and has been a fixture
of life in Point Pleasant ever since.
The monster is a perfect example of
iconic modern American folklore. There's
even a Mothman statue in the middle of
downtown. Hi! It speaks to the idea that
this really is modern folklore. It came
from this town. Like, we're staking this
spot in this part of the world as
Mothman. So they're really uniting
Mothman and Point Pleasant and West
Virginia . On December 15th, 1967 this
paranormal activity culminated in a very
real tragedy. The collapse of Silver
Bridge. Some claim Mothman was the cause
of the accident. Others say he was
actually meant to forewarn the town of
the catastrophe.
But how do you explain the Mothman
phenomenon? Was it an elaborate hoax or
did people simply mistake something real
for an imaginary creature? Or maybe it
was something truly so bizarre that it
just can't be easily explained.
I'm Dr. Emily Zarqa and this is Monstrum.
On November 12 1966 in Clendenin West
Virginia, five grave diggers claimed to
have seen what they described as a man
with wings gliding over their heads. Eye
witness Kenneth Duncan later said the
beam was gliding through the trees and
was in sight for about a minute. But it
was here where Mothman became a legend.
I'm at the spot of what is widely
believed to be the earliest officially
reported Mothman sighting.
What used to be the West Virginia
ordinance works munitions plant. Better
known as the TNT area. On November 15
1966 two young married couples, Roger and
Linda Scarberry and Steve and Mary Malec
were driving around the TNT area when
they reportedly spotted what looked like
a man with large wings standing in the
middle of the road. Steve described the
creature as being six or seven feet tall
with a ten-foot wingspan and red eyes
about two inches in diameter and six
inches apart. Linda claims she couldn't
see a head or arms but also saw glowing
red eyes when the car headlights hit the
figure who seemed to shy away from the
light. Frightened, they quickly sped away
from the figure. But shortly after while
traveling along route 62 they spotted it
again. This time it followed them.
They claimed they couldn't shake the
creature even when the car reached
speeds as fast as a hundred miles per hour.
This is Denny Bellamy, the Mason County
Visitors Bureau Executive Director. Denny
has lived in the Point Pleasant Mason
County area for over 60 years.
I was in third grade. My neighbors saw it and
said there's a large there's a six-foot
bird with big red eyes and massive wings
chasing cars in the TNT Area. And in fact, it
kept up with Roger Scarberry's 57 Chevy.
Right on this road. This road, as you can
see, it's like a drag strip. And that's
what Roger Scarberry was doing out here -
was drag racing. There were scratch marks
on the ceiling of his car and he was
upset and he was scared. Shaken by the
experience, the group drove straight to
the sheriff's office to file a report
around 2:00 a.m. that morning. Officers
immediately set out to investigate, but
by the time they arrived at the TNT site
no evidence of the creature could be
found. I'm here at the Point Pleasant
Public Library doing some research
looking through their archiv.There's a
lot of stuff here I'm super excited to
explore this. This is a copy of the original
Point Pleasant register of the first
Mothman sighting Wednesday November 16th.
In the morning after,
couple sees man-sized bird creature.
Well there's drawings. There's drawings!
Eyewitness sketch of Mothman verified by
others one of the original eyewitnesses.
Both were slightly pale and tired from
lack of sleep during the night following
their harrowing experience. 'If I hadn't
it while by myself I wouldn't have said
anything but there were four of us who
saw it.' They speculated that the thing
was living in the vacant power plant
possibly one of the huge boilers. There
are pigeons in all the other buildings
but not in that one. I love finding new
info! This was a top-secret government
facility.
They made all the explosives from the
atomic bomb. It employed all the people
from the town. You would come to work
here on to a bus that all the windows
were blacked out of so you couldn't see
anything in the facility. And they drove
you right to where you were working. You did your job, you got back on the bus, and
they never saw anything. And the day we
dropped the bomb on Hiroshima, they
closed the facility. That was it. They were
done. We're going to go look at the
bunkers that give the TNT area its name.
It's where they stored the explosives, TNT, and the nitroglycerin . It's
creepy first start bringing people out
here there were still rusted
hands of gunpowder. So here's definitely
some Mothman graffiti. I mean we have the
humanoid structure. We have the wings, the
you see two large eyes.
I grew up in forests but there's
something about the abandoned buildings
and the legends and the real history
that there's a spooky vibe.
I mean it's honestly really really
creepy. We're walking into one of the
buildings that used to be part of the
TNT site. So we're gonna go in. We have no
idea what's inside. It's pitch black.
Let's see what happens. Okay, I don't know
how far back it goes. Look at the lights! I
don't know what it was used for and
there's stuff everywhere.It
definitely looks like it could be
haunted, especially about the workers who
used to be he. You never know.
I just kicked something! Okay no more!
I'm creeped out now that I have been in that
building. Over the following three days
after the November 15th sighting at
least eight more people reported similar
creatures. My brother and I said, don't look
but there's something there beside the
car. If  I'd rolled my window down I
could've touched it.
And then it jumped on the hood and just
sit there and just squatted. Kind of look
this. But it did have the biggest red
eyes - and it run right past the car and
it jumped up in there and just opened up
the biggest pretty set of bird wings.
Because you could see the feathers and
everything just opened up and just went
off in the night like that. For one year
starting in November 1966, over a hundred
eye witnesses reported accounts of the
Mothman in this area. Almost all agreed
on the same points. The monster was as
large as larger than a big man, it had
wings but no feathers, and took off into
the air straight like a helicopter
gliding through the sky. Its face was
indistinguishable besides two large
glowing red eyes.
The town's population was so intrigued
by the creature that hundreds of local
residents some armed and went hunting for
the winged figure. There was a police
officer directing traffic.There was so
much. Newspapers are often the first
indicators of an emerging legend.They
help rumors become lore as more
variations are published and told to the
public. Mothman was no exception. He even
received his famous title from an
anonymous Ohio newspaper copy editor who
likely gave the mysterious bird the name
Mothman after the famous comic book
character Batman, who is the subject of a
popular TV shot at the time. Later that
month, the Beckley Herald Dispatch
renamed the Mothman as the Mason bird
monster but that didn't quite stick.
Were the Mothman eyewitnesses in the
1960s really seeing a monster?
Some people certainly saw something in
the night sky. The sheer number of
sightings might be an example of the
psychological and social phenomenon
known as mass hysteria. The textbook
definition of mass hysteria says it is a
form of mass contagion in which an
irrational belief or behavior grips a
group or community. The size of a small
town link Point Pleasant offered a
unique social environment. Residents
either had a Mothman story themselves or
knew someone who did which allowed the
story to circulate in a relatively
closed inner network that could bolster
the belief in the creature. What is
undoubtedly very real as the event that
stopped the Mothman sightings of the
1960s. On December 15 1967, exactly 13
months after the first reported sighting
of Mothman, an estimated 31 cars and
trucks plunged into the Ohio River after
the bridge connecting Ohio and West
Virginia collapsed. 64 people went into
the water 46 of them died.
It officially ended the Mothman. That's
what ended the story.
When the bridge fell, no one wanted to
hear about the Mothman anymore.
It was ultimately discovered that a
single eye bar, 55 feet long, fractured
causing the pin holding it in place
to become loose and the tragic chain of
events to follow. Survivors and witnesses
recall that the bridge shook violently
before it collapsed. Some even say they
saw Mothman on the bridge days before.
This is really where the myth of the
Mothman as a harbinger of death started.
Was he a warning to the townspeople or a
curse being bringing destruction with
him? Some people speculated that Mothman and the bridge collapse had something to
do with a rumored legend known as the
Curse of Cornstalk. a Shawnee leader of
the indigenous people, Chief
Cornstalk and his men fought in the
Battle of Point Pleasant against
colonial troops in 1774. Local legend in
Point Pleasant said that with his dying
breath, Cornstalk cursed the town for 200
years. Some people even speculated that the
Mothman was sent by cornstalk himself
from beyond the grave.
But in 2006, it was revealed that the
rumored curse of cornstalk was nothing
more than a myth. A rediscovered
historical pageant play was found in an
old grade school in Point Pleasant that
includes Cornstalk's Curse. Most likely,
the playwright added it in to give the
performance a little more drama. ...and the
energies of its people paralyzed by the
stain of our blood so saying he fell
dead by the side of the son. There's the
curse! Maybe the Mothman sightings can be
explained by something from the natural
world. It was proposed early on that the
Mothman was actually a sandhill crane
when a West Virginia University
professor told the press in an article
published December 1st 1966 quote 'I
definitely believe that's what these
people are seeing this is the sandhill
crane.' Dr. Robert Smith of the West
Virginia University biology department
said the description fits that of a
sandhill crane. Sandhill cranes have an
average wingspan of around 6.5 feet and
are about 3 to 4 feet tall. They also
happen to have red patches around their eyes. But Dr. Z
you may be wondering, do sandhill cranes
ever make it to West Virginia? The answer
is yes! Because I am a crazy bird person
and this Mothman thing was driving me
insane, I contacted the Cornell Lab of
Ornithology for sandhill crane data from
the 1960s. While they couldn't give me
anything from that time period, I did
find that sightings of sandhill cranes
happened today. At least 28 of them have
been spotted in West Virginia between
January 2017 and August 2019. Sometimes in large groups. Brenda Knight the
sister-in-law of one of the November 15
witnesses, said quote 'We all thought it
was a mutant sandhill crane because of
the toxins in the swamp.' Maybe Brenda was
on to something. She wasn't the only one
to think that illegally dumped chemicals
had caused animal mutations. The
munitions plant that gave the TNT area
its name was built during World War II
to produce and store explosives from
1942 to 1945. After the war, much of the
land was given to the Department of
Natural Resources. It became a wildlife
reserve in 1966 and is now called the
McClintock Wildlife Management Area. The
mutation theory might have a little more
validity to it than some of the other
explanations. In 198, a red water seep
was discovered in the area which led to
the realization that contamination had
occurred. The red water is a result of a
cold water and select mixture used to
rinse the TNT. According to the US Army
Corps of Engineers, the red water was
discharged directly into the Ohio River
through a pipe located about one foot
offshore. After becoming part of the
national priority list in 1983, cleanup
became the focus and ground water
extraction was completed in 1997. So how
could you explain mothman's infamous
glowing red eyes? Another type of bird
was quickly thrown out as a possible
explanation to the humanoid flying
creature. One known for its silent
nocturnal flights - owls. It's always owls!
Birds eyes appear red when a bright
light is shined at them because of the
vascular membrane that shows through the pigment layer of the retina. An effect
referred to as eyeshine. One owl is known for its very dramatic
eyeshine. The barred owl is a large species with
a rounded head common throughout the
southeast that prefers to roost in old
trees in open forests. Extra blood
vessels around their eyes make them glow
more red than other species. Officials at
the McClintock Wildlife Management Area
told the Audubon Society who also looked
at the explanation for Mothman.
That the area has a healthy population
of the species some people in Point
Pleasant argue that Mothman was really
just a lost weather balloon or even an
elaborate hoax a local rumor exists
alongside Mothman himself what about a
local teenage prankster who found it fun
to jump out at cars driving at night in
the TNT area while wearing a Halloween
costume hoaxes like these could have
happened on more than one occasion but
that doesn't really explain the Mothman
phenomenon you're probably wondering how
we've gotten this far without mentioning
the Mothman Prophecies written by John
keel the book and its 2002 film
adaptation are the most important texts
for how the legend took root outside of
Point Pleasant Hill was a journalist and
paranormal investigator who went to
Point Pleasant in December 1966 to
explore the Mothman and other
supernatural sightings in the area he
interviewed a lot of the original
witnesses and even claimed to have
experience with what he calls ultra
terrestrials I read the whole thing and
it's a doozy honestly the book seems
more concerned about UFOs and men in
black than Mothman regardless of how
factual the Mothman Prophecies is or not
the 1975 book and the movie did have one
indisputable result they made Mothman
globally recognized and turned the town
of Point Pleasant into a tourist
destination. Quite frankly, I mean there's
only one Mothman and there's only one
Point Pleasant. People were really
interested in that. Although I wasn't and
actually the town wasn't. The town didn't
believe it. Although there
kept on being sightings. The newspaper
kept writing about it. But it was mostly
tongue-in-cheek. It was all that. But
frankly still is today for most.
One time someone said, 'We'd like
to talk to some people that don't
believe in the Mothman.' I said 'Pick any
one on Main Street!' One year after the
movie came out they erected a statue of
him on Main Street in 2003. We're
dedicating the statue and we're all
kind of...the mayor and everyone's kind of
like 'Jeez!' you know. The mayor has to
speak at the dedication. I go over to see
what's going on. I had to come back. I
said you probably ought to put a suit and tie on.
He said, 'What's going on?' I said
CBS is here, CBS Sunday morning. Bill Geist is out
there. That's Willie Geist's father and
that's how it started. When Bill
Geist showed up, I became a Mothman
believer. In 2005, a whole Mothman
museum opened up. Created by Jeff
Walmsley, Point Pleasant resident and
local Mothman expert, it sees thousands
of visitors a year. A lot of the movie
props that we have here in the museum
were donated and that was kind of like
the catalyst to get the museum going. The
Mothman festival was started back in
2002, but it's a big boon to the tourism
here. I mean, with the festival and the
museum, people have embraced it you know.
You still have skeptics which is fine. I
mean, you know, I'm not out to convince
anybody of anything. I mean everything in
the museum is for people to decide for
themselves.
They weren't sure that they really
wanted the Mothman in our town. But
the Mothman festival grew every year. We
had to! They were all coming! We had no
choice. Tourism has grown and grown and
our entire state has embraced it now. That
is the one weekend here that the entire town
will tell you anything you want to know
about Mothman. And we just enjoy looking
at everybody. It's entertaining for us.
How much money is made on average now? At least probably two million flows down on
Main Street on that weekend which is
probably more than the rest of year. You
know, we attract 10 to 12 thousand people
so the town's population doubles, you
know. The local people they're used to it.
I mean they're used to the attention and
everything and don't get me wrong - Point
Pleasant has a lot to offer rather than
just Mothman, you know. Native American
history, riverboat history, Farm Museum,
River Museum. All that kind of stuff.
To me, I think, you know, the Mothman story
is just a nice way to get people's
attention. They come here and they're like
oh you know we got the flood wall, murals.
You know, we got the river museum.
I don't see anything negative about it,
you know. With the help of the Internet,
Mothman has become a global phenomenon.
Online rumors circulate frequently. Some
claiming that he was spotted before the
Chernobyl disaster and even in the smoke
of the towers at 9/11. Most recently, the
largest number of Mothman sightings in
one area occurred in Chicago in 2017.
There were more than 20 reports of a
winged humanoid in Chicago from April to
July of that year. Whether you believe in
him or not, Mothman has become a cultural touchstone
- a monster myth that inspires both fear
and fascination. Legends only truly take
root when they become a subject of
conflicting opinions. They are born in
stories told and retold with countless
contradictions
and disputes. Mothman is no different.
He's been demonized and deified in
almost equal measure.
Mothman shows us how a local phenomenon
can become a global sensation. People
identify with Mothman.
He's a rumor and an outcast a monster
who was ultimately embraced by the small
town that once feared him. Whether the
people of Point Pleasant liked it or not,
Mothman is now part of their town's
identity. It can even be argued that the
people of Point Pleasant embraced the
creature because it made their little
part of the world visible to a lot more
people. Like other small towns, a portion
of the town's economic survival depends
on its ability to attract outsiders. It
does feel like a ruin and I always think
that ruins carry some kind of energy
that allows them to attract myths like
this. I'm not surprised, being here now,
that there were so many Mothman
sightings. I'm actually not. I don't know.
I think it's probably a bird or some kind
of giant bird maybe - maybe just
abnormally large and freakish. But
there's something - and the way this
forest is so creepy - there's definitely a
way that imagination could have run wild
a hundred percent. Personal opinion.  I
have also been in a lot of creepy
forests and
this one takes the cake. I don't know.
If I was a monster this is where I hang out.
A legend survives when it is able to
adapt to the current cultural moment. The
Mothman has done this astonishingly well.
He's gone from mysterious humanoid to
prophetic demon, guardian angel to old
for terrestrial. Scary monster to cute
cryptid and everything in between.
Interestingly, no witness has ever
reported this creature harmed a human.
Maybe he really is just your friendly
neighborhood Mothman. Mothman is about
number five on the list of things I
don't want to run into out here. What is number 1? Snakes.
I do not like snakes.